[Music]
picture New York City and you're
probably thinking about Midtown Times
Square the Empire State Building Grand
Central
this is midtown Manhattan tourists flock
to it while locals often try and fail to
avoid it but there's more to this part
of town than tourist traps and traffic
congestion Midtown has been electrified
by a bolt Brooklyn hip Wall Street money
maybe it's time we took a second look
[Music]
Midtown is everything between 14th
Street and Central Park South it's the
world's largest central business
district it also has some of the most
expensive real estate and it doesn't get
any richer than 5th Avenue which
commands the world's highest retail
rents but if there's one building more
responsible than any other for midtown
success it's this one built in 1913
Grand Central Terminal helped spark a
boom in construction that made Midtown
the center of American capitalism this
audacious building is used by more than
a million people a week a century after
it was built it has only now reached
capacity that's future proofing
New York embraces eating out there are
over 45,000 restaurants in the city it
would take a hundred and twenty five
years to eat in everyone not saying you
should appear in Midtown the restaurant
scene is embracing change a number of
Brooklyn institutions have jumped the
river
Roberta's pizza started on the other
side of the East River in 2008 but their
second outpost is based in urban space
food hall smack dab in Midtown it could
be fooled into thinking this is
Williamsburg not Park Ave another
Brooklyn import is itchy R on the
Japanese ramen chain whose first u.s.
restaurant opened in Bushwick in 2016
here you can sit with a group or in
splendid isolation in one of the so
called flavor concentration booths very
serious
[Music]
but if you want to swap Brooklyn cool
for something a bit more luxury we've
got the spot the office is an intimate
speakeasy offering pre-prohibition style
cocktails and a food menu to match
you'll find it hidden away on the 35th
floor of the super swanky Mandarin
Oriental this is one of the most
expensive hotels in New York room start
at around $1,000 a night but there are
113 other hotels in Midtown offering
plenty of choices so forget the old
wisdom that the excitement is basically
anywhere but Midtown this part of
Manhattan has something new and exciting
to offer whether its high-end or rough
and ready
[Music]
you